he's Ryan Donato the Bruins Center and
also played college at Harvard still
taking classes there he joins us on the
program Ryan good morning how are you
good morning how's it going good where
are you right now I am currently in a
hotel room in Dallas Texas right now
okay now when were you last in class at
Harvard I was in class Tuesday morning
we played Monday night against Columbus
and then Tuesday morning I had class
from 9:00 to 10:00 10:00 to 11:00 11:00
to 12:00 then 12 to 1 so I was pretty
busy Tuesday what is it like though
taking classes and then playing
professionally I mean it's difficult
obviously you get the extreme highs and
you by playing in the games with
adrenaline rushes and then you go to
class and get back to reality where it's
kind of low-key and nobody really cares
about what you did last night nobody
really knows anything about it so it's
kind of it's kind of nice when you think
about it because you can kind of just go
back to being a regular student but it
was a weird transition at first
what are your teachers say about
excusing you like an excused absence
most of them have been good about it so
far I mean as long as I get most of my
work done on time and I'm not kind of a
force in the class where I'm creating a
lot of issues I think I just try to make
as many of the sections as I can that's
what's important for me is making sure I
get to the sections and making sure I
don't fall behind too far in my studies
and with that I can try to keep
everybody happy and hopefully not far to
fall too far behind
teammates give you grief make fun of you
oh yeah oh yeah absolutely I think the
first first day I came back I had a one
guy say Arana you're going on for a
morning ski and I was like yeah and
they're like oh we thought you guys had
homework again he didn't skate again so
I was like okay here it comes
do they give you a grief with going to
Harvard a little bit we have a couple
Cornell guys a couple to you guys so it
kind of we have that kind of Boston
school rivalry and we have the Ivy
League rival e at the same time so they
get it a little bit but nothing nothing
too bad so far but those were safety
schools for you right Ryan me a little
bit nothing crazy
yeah I think I can imagine that to those
guys now you got a nickname not yet a
little bit maybe Don but nothing nothing
crazy I mean I've only been around for
two days so what was your dad's nickname
um I think they called him Heavy D back
in the day yeah I can't remember yeah
that's it was but yeah that's pretty
good but I don't know if I could take
the same nickname I don't know if I
would like that and your dad played how
long in the NHL I think my dad plays for
12 or 13 years what did you learn from
him I mean I learned that hockey is a
business I think that's one of the most
important things that I learned from him
and at the end of the day they're gonna
play who's the best players and and it's
not about making everybody happy and
they can share everybody's getting the
time it's a business and and it's a lot
of harsh realities in hockey and it's
gonna be a tough but there's gonna be a
lot of good good experiences as well
have you gotten your first Bruins
paycheck yet I did yeah I did yeah I got
my first pitch I don't know what I've
done anything on yet told not to spend
too much money but I think I need to buy
a couple some new clothes here and there
I'm falling behind on the fashion trends
compared to the team did you just stare
at that check when you got it
a little bit yeah I mean I didn't even
know what to do with it I mean I've
never had that much money in my bank
account at all so I mean it's pretty
cool to see that and what what's the
difference between the pay with the
Bruins and in the miners I mean I think
it's a pretty large portion I mean I
think it's 70 in the in the in the AHL
and then a 25 but there's a lot of
different things that go into the works
because I'm joining late in the season
and there's a signing bonus and there's
a lot of different things that come into
play but there's a huge difference
between the salaries of playing in the
NHL and AHL for me what are you studying
it Harvard after me it's sociology I
know what are you gonna do with that
hopefully play hockey that's a good
answer
that's an honest answer there
I appreciate that hey good luck with it
with trying to balance this don't let
these guys rough you up a little bit
they're too much with uh you know I'll
try not to use big words that they may
not be able to understand
I can feel a there are a couple there
way yeah Thank You Ryan good luck thank
you very much appreciate it
Ryan Donato he's the Bruins Center
sociology what are you gonna do with
that play play hockey for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]